one of America's key allies has executed
its 100th person this year and I'm not
talking about lethal injections here
Saudi Arabia's preferred method of
execution is good old-fashioned
beheading and they're the only country
in the world to still use it in fact
after eclipsing 2014's total of 87 Saudi
is on pace to beat his own record of 192
executions in a year earlier this year
the government posted an ad for more
executioner's of course Saudi isn't the
only place where death sentences are
imposed nor does it carry out the most
executions that would be China followed
by Iran and the u.s. is no stranger to
the death penalty either but Saudi
Arabia's execution rate per capita is 30
times higher than the US and while the
u.s. reserves a death penalty for murder
or treason Saudi Arabia will execute for
many nonviolent offenses in fact almost
half of the executions so far in 2015
have been for these crimes which include
drug related charges adultery and
sorcery and the courts that hand down
these sentences aren't exactly known for
being fair according to Amnesty
International trials and death penalty
cases are often held in secret
defendants are rarely allowed formal
representation by lawyers they may be
convicted solely on the basis of
confessions obtained under duress I'm
pretty sure that means torture and in
February this year a new anti-terrorism
law came into effect the government will
consider you a terrorist if you
destabilize the security of society or
the state harm the reputation of the
state contact individuals and groups
opposed to the kingdom or call for a
theist for those accused of terrorism
are tried in a special anti-terrorism
court which hands down death sentences
so are we going to see more job postings
for executioner's
[Music]